hypocrisy no longer knows any bounds in
the American right wing
if I say to you lock her up what do you
think of if you were paying attention
during the 2016 election when I say
Locker up your mind should immediately
go to all of those calls to lock up
Hillary during the Republican National
Convention everyone from Donald Trump's
now indicted National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn who was there of egging on
crowds at Trump's rallies or the RNC
wherever to lock her up lock her up to
crowds chanting it at Trump's rallies
while Trump looks around smiling and
pleased to Trump's tweets to Trump's
debate statement that if he were in
charge of the justice system that
Hillary would be in jail they've been
calling for Hillary to be locked up
despite not having been charged with any
crime despite the obvious reality that
Hillary Clinton is not going to be
charged with any crime and recent
recently Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi said rather than impeach Trump
she'd like to see him in prison now we
can argue about whether Nancy Pelosi's
position on impeachment makes sense we
can have a debate about all of that but
there is no question that this is not a
unique thing on one side of the aisle on
the one hand Nancy Pelosi says she'd
like to see Trump in prison for the list
of crimes that Robert Muller said there
is substantial evidence for and on the
other hand lock her up has been you know
a a stalwart fixture of the American
right for three years at this point but
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity is
outraged at Nancy Pelosi saying that
calls to lock up political opponents are
quote despicable does hypocrisy no
longer mattered you double standards no
longer make any difference and the
answer is they don't
to the right we've been pointing that
out for a long time check out what Sean
Hannity had to say despite these obvious
flaws as bi as this deception Muller's
report the irrefutable fact that there
was no collusion of course the rage
Trump Democratic Party they're just
hell-bent on one thing one thing only
and that's impeaching the president they
don't have a reason they don't state a
reason but of course they get the
assistance of
the psychotic media mobs conspiracy
theorists liars and tonight this is no
longer a democratic party like of scoop
Jackson even Joe Lieberman instead it is
now the party of anti Trump rage and
psychosis and for some reason even
impeaching Trump apparently is not
enough that speaker Pelosi now
apparently telling senior Democrats
she'd like to see Trump behind bars
based on no actual crime she wants a
political opponent locked up in prison
that happens in banana republics beyond
despicable behavior and by the way they
would literally turn in many ways the
USA into a country we no longer
recognize wait wait hold on a second
you're saying that telling political
opponents not charged of any crime that
you want them locked up or you plan to
lock them up or you would lock them up
if you were in charge or you're saying
Sean that that's unbecoming of the
United States and it's like what happens
in so-called banana republics I got it
well remember when Donald Trump said
this to Hillary Clinton during a debate
in 2016 you know it is it's just awfully
good that someone with the temperament
of Donald Trump is not in charge of the
law in our country because you'd be in
jail
Secretary Clinton Jeff Sessions
previously chanted lock her up there's a
very long list but the problem is Nancy
Pelosi wanting to see Trump in jail for
crimes that the Moller report says there
is substantial evidence of irony is dead
satire no longer exists or never existed
on the right intellectual consistency is
completely irrelevant I've talked about
how Donald Trump has weaponized
ignorance in this country he's also
weaponized hypocrisy for all of my focus
on Trump I keep trying to remind you
that Trump is a symptom not the disease
this is a really good example the
disease is the anti intellectualism that
has spread throughout the country and
American conservatism and has allowed
someone like Trump to come in
Trump appeal
to the basest instincts of the American
right wouldn't be possible if they were
not appealable to I guess is what I'm
trying to say on that basis weaponizing
they're ignorant about everything from
trade to immigration as Donald Trump
successfully did during his presidential
campaign that is not something that
Trump created Trump took advantage of it
and in the same way there is this
immunity to their own hypocrisy that
Donald Trump is able to weaponize that
the American right is able to weaponize
that propaganda outlets like Fox News
certainly know how to weaponize and this
problem precedes Donald Trump this
problem is going to continue after
Donald Trump there is no doubt
whatsoever and this is just one example
of that it's an embarrassing one but on
the Fox News echo chamber it does really
well and it really fires up the base